all right so it's not just lululemon of
course this entire
sort of debacle is designed in order to
push corporations to do what the left
wants them to do the latest element of
this of course
is toyota has now announced it will stop
any donation
to any republican member of congress who
voted against certifying the 2020
presidential election
now presumably toyota is not going to do
this for for example jamie raskin
from maryland who you'll remember last
time around in 2016 voted against
certifying the election but according to
citizens for responsibility and ethics
in washington the company's pac
has given 56 000 to 38 members of
congress who objected to the
certification of the election on january
6th
and it is a very short step from this
particular thing listen i don't think
that anyone should have voted against
the certification of the election i
don't think there is a legal basis to do
so
i've been very very clear about this
with that said i don't think that
corporations
should be forced to to boycott
politicians
who agree with their particular business
agenda because
those politicians also supported a thing
with which
the company was not involved so for
example i do not think that companies
should be forced to stop giving money if
they if they are
into giving money to democrats based on
their economic agenda for some reason i
don't think that there should be a lot
of social pressure to force
those companies to stop giving money to
democrats based on the fact
that democrats support broadly speaking
crackdowns on religious freedom right if
it's a company that's not involved with
any of that sort of stuff i don't really
think those two things are related
but we have now come to the point where
anything that becomes a leftist talking
point is an excuse
to push corporations to not give to
republicans overall
that is the goal january 6th is just the
excuse and if it weren't january 6th it
would be something else it would be
anybody who supported donald trump
cannot be supported
by any sort of corporation because if
they do then they are supporting all of
the evils and excesses of donald trump
in a statement issued on thursday
japan-based automaker said
it had decided to stop contributing to
those members of congress who contested
the certification
toyota is committed to supporting and
promoting actions that further our
democracy said toyota
this is the same thing that stacey
abrams finally accomplished in georgia
when he saw corporations divesting from
the state of georgia because georgia
passed
a law voting shoring up voter id for
example and then
she realized oh this was a bad idea and
tried to back off of that toyota says
our company has long-standing
relationships with members of congress
across the political spectrum
especially those representing our u.s
operations our bipartisan pac equally
supports democrats and republicans
running for congress in fact
in 2021 the vast majority of
contributions went to democrats and
republicans who supported the
certification of the 2020 election
we understand that the pac decision to
support select members of congress who
contested the results
troubled some stakeholders we are
actively listening to our stakeholders
and at this time we've decided to stop
contributing to these members of
congress who contested the certification
of certain states in the 2020 election
the reason i pause on the word
stakeholders is because this is deeply
indicative
of a perverse view of how business is
supposed to work and there are two views
of how business is supposed to work one
is what is called shareholder capitalism
pushed by people like milton friedman
and the basic idea here is that a
company's main duty is to its
shareholders you buy stock in a company
and now the company has a duty to you
the company has a duty to create a
program that will allow for long-term
earnings the company has a duty
to ensure that your stock price over
time does not go down that they make
good business decisions
and that's what shareholder capitalism
is all about that the people who
actually own a share of the company
are the people to whom the company's
board is responsible stakeholder
capitalism is a very different thing
stakeholder capitalism is a term that's
been coined by
quote-unquote intellectual elites to
suggest a system
in which corporations are answerable not
just to their own shareholders but to
the public at large
which really means to government actors
and the media stakeholders are people
who do not own chairs in the company who
don't own any they don't buy toyota cars
they don't have a share of toyota stock
they're just anyone who's affected by
toyota meaning
a person in the world and so if any
person in the world has a complaint
about toyota toyota will now respond to
those people
which of course means they are not
responding to economic concerns they are
not
focusing in on what makes their product
better and less expensive for the
consumer instead they are focused in
on pleasing particular political actors
who are the loudest stakeholder
capitalism again
is just a way of saying that your
corporate overlords ought to be
responding not to market incentives but
to non-market incentives they are not
responding
to the demands of the market they are
responding instead to the loudest
political actors out there
which is a form of corporatism in which
corporations act hand in glove with the
government and with the democrat media
complex
in order to cram down institutional
power
my new book the authoritarian moment is
all about this it's about how the
institutions of power have been hijacked
and weaponized by the left
stakeholder capitalism is a very big
aspect of this and this is why you are
seeing the media cover
lululemon because you're a stakeholder
in lululemon you see you don't own
stocks you don't even own
lemon pants you're a dude but still you
have a steak in what lube lemon does
same thing with toyota you have a steak
in what they do therefore you ought to
run
their company hey this is not a recipe
for economic success or
political health for a nation i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the ben shapiro
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button so you stay up to date
with all our future content